that's enough BDSM in the kitchen let's
make some matzo balls everyone I'm Aaron
and I'm Leslie we've been friends for a
long time but despite that we haven't
really cooked for each other a lot which
is weird because we both care about food
a lot oh yeah I grew up eating a lot of
Cantonese cooking because my parents are
from southern China and I am Jewish so I
grew up eating a lot of Jewish foods I
thought it might be cool if we went out
got some groceries put some cute meals
for each other and maybe in the process
learn a little bit about each other's
cultures I think that sounds like a plan
you ready I'm so ready you ready to get
some Chinese groceries yeah let's do it
we are in the Chinese supermarket we're
about to get all the ingredients for my
ketchup shrimp so we got the ingredients
for the Chinese dishes that Leslie's
gonna be making and now we just got to
get the food for the Jewish dishes that
I'm gonna make okay but wait hold up
what do I mean when I say Jewish food
traditionally observant Jews keep kosher
which means they can only eat certain
things the meals I'm making today are
Jewish dishes but I'm not using kosher
ingredients they're not being cooked in
a kosher kitchen so they're not kosher
they are however delicious so I'm making
something it's gonna be like very
classic very standard potato latkes
which normally you eat during Hanukkah
you can sleep them at any time and
another thing I'm gonna make is matzo
ball soup which is something that I ate
every Friday night every Shabbat I'm
going to be making ketchup fried shrimp
so my dad made this for me all the time
growing up but I haven't had it in a
while
actually I'm a little nervous because
I've never actually made matzo ball soup
I've been and it made ketchup right Ruth
are you ready I'm ready
what is your favorite memory involving
matzo ball soup growing up my family
wasn't super religious but we did pretty
consistently like recognized Shabbat at
time of the week where you slow down and
you rest
pretty much every Shabbat dinner had to
have matzo ball soup it was like a
staple it was like a given locking dance
making latkes why do you think a lot
cuts because lockers are something you
traditionally eat during Hanukkah
growing up as a kid some of my favorite
memories are from Hanukkah just being
with your family and getting presents
and eating good food and it's such a fun
holiday just do it to taste that's how
my parents my grandma is this is
actually delicious my god just ketchup
and some tomato paste and like soy sauce
but it's like so good so you can just go
ahead and like cut off the heads shrimpy
I'm so sorry we're gonna put all the
ginger into the pan my dad is from
Guangzhou China which is a port city
it's really close to the ocean I just
remember sitting down at dinner and then
getting so excited when I found out that
he made ketchup fried shrimp I feel so
lucky because he got that training in
China and now when he makes dinner for
us he makes six or seven dishes it's
ridiculous this looks amazing
I know where do you eat it yeah
this is really good the matzo balls are
a little dense
if it been my mom you know they'd
probably be a little fluffier it's just
like tastes like Judaism I thought this
would taste so weird with applesauce but
it works the sweetness of the apple
sauce and the tankiness of the sour
cream and the salty oily potato eat
cárdenas of the latke I just makes sense
let's dig in
this is actually really good I'm so
happy I got to introduce you to this new
dish I'm gonna be a piece of shelves in
this trim and I don't even care it's
just so good I mean I kind of just want
to finish this TBH I was just like
really nice getting to try foods that
you grew up with trying such a huge
country in seven different regions and
ethnic groups and it was nice to learn
about where specifically your family
came from and the kinds of things that
you grew up with Aaron yeah I'm so happy
you're my friend
Oh Leslie I'm happy you're my friend I
think I make a good team sorry Oh
[Music]